l'histoire commence en 2017 pierre et sa
femme au Portugal et décide de faire un
tour d'Europe et mettre en location leur
appartement situé dans le 16e
arrondissement de Marseille
là tout va bien c'est ça
la retraite donc on a eu on a eu
l'occasion d'acheter un petit camping et
on est parti donc avec des conseils de
la famille de laisser pas votre maison
comme ça louez-la ça fera un petit
péculent en plus vous pourrez profiter
un petit peu plus c'est ce qu'on a fait
donc vous louez votre maison vous
décidez de partir combien de temps à la
base au départ on n'avait pas de but
précis c'était deux trois ans c'était on
avait ce qu'il fait en Espagne Portugal
ensuite on s'est arrêté au Portugal
puisqu'on a rencontré pas mal de
français là-bas qui vivent là-bas donc
on s'est fait c'est fait au top et donc
décidé de louer votre maison voilà on a
loué la maison en attendant et
malheureusement pour nous la maladie
nous a rattrapé il a fallu rentrer et le
covid
finalement et
là donc nous avons fait appel à l'agence
Stéphane Plaza je sais pas si on peut le
dire mais qui a fait le nécessaire pour
que cette personne là la locataire prend
de congé de l'appartement ça a été fait
dans les règles de l'art et au moment de
partir cette dame là décidée
de payer le crédit de la maison oui oui
vous habitiez dans ce logement voilà il
a il a été loué donc à la suite de
problèmes de santé vous décidez de
rentrer que vous l'avez dit vous résigné
le bail en respectant la procédure vous
envoyez un les recommandé tu t'es fait
dans les règles
pas mal de trois mois et puis en grande
partie vous partez rapidement elle ne
veut absolument rien savoir le problème
c'est qu'on ne sait pas
on sait pas ce que ce qu'elle veut ce
qu'elle a on sait pas voilà elle reste
là elle veut pas c'est incroyable alors
chaque fois là pour la traversée Verne
alors voilà à chaque fois le profil de
toutes les fissures de la de la loi
voilà juridique
alors elle refuse de quitter les lieux
est-ce que vous avez pensé et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est une question il faut pas
le faire est-ce que vous avez pensé
d'intervenir voilà un peu Manu military
pour la sortir on aurait dû le faire on
aurait dû le faire à mon avis on aurait
dû le faire avant de mettre de tout ça
en route mais c'est vrai qu'après après
après on a eu l'occasion de le faire
mais notre avocat nous a écouté on va
essayer de rester carré on va essayer de
rester dans les rails de la loi donc il
doit déconseiller fortement là si vous
ne regardez
Pierre et Marie sont eu la bonne
attitude voilà mais si aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour eux ils ont eu la bonne
attitude heureusement que vous n'avez
pas vous n'êtes pas mis vous ne vous
êtes pas mis en faute parce que c'est de
la première chose qui vient à l'esprit
je sais qu'il y a des gens qui sont s'il
y a des gens qui sont dans votre cas ils
première chose qui vient à l'esprit si
on va les sortir et derrière ça se
retourne contre vous donc c'est la
double peine et si c'est encore pire
alors est-ce que la police est la
justice font le nécessaire pour avancer
sur ce dossier où est-ce qu'il n'y a
rien à faire il y a eu rien de fait il y
a rien de fait si vous voulez il y a eu
il y a eu un petit un petit problème
c'est que l'huissier a fait quelques
impairs dans le dossier donc il a il a
eu un petit peu de retard sur sur le
dossier bon tout est rentré dans l'ordre
tout a été fait comme il fallait que ça
soit fait et aujourd'hui si on a bien le
jour d'aujourd'hui le le document donc
le fameux dossier est à la préfecture il
est sur le bureau du préfet et Monsieur
le Préfet de Région donc de chez nous il
n'a plus qu'à signer le document
d'expulsion de cette dame là donc
ce mois-ci donc et on attend tous les
jours est-ce qu'il va se passer on a la
chance sur disque ça se passe c'est que
ça va dépasser
[Musique]
sont toujours pas parti
voilà pierre et Maryse vivant encore à
l'étroit dans un camping-car vous avez
décidé de vivre dans un camping-car
comment ça se passe vous savez avoir
quand on le voit comme ça il y a des
gens qui vont dire c'est retraités ils
ont de l'argent ils ont ils ont acheté
un bon truc c'est un engine c'est un 12
ans c'est nager qui a énormément de
kilomètres qu'on a pris
un crédit sur 10 ans pour se payer ça
pour pouvoir
prendre un crédit pour payer pour
prendre un camping-car on a un crédit de
10 ans dessus on payait 350 euros par
mois je peux vous dire la somme donc on
est des petits retraités on n'est pas et
si vous voulez c'est magnifique un
appareil pareil mais c'est magnifique
quand nous partez en vacances portez 15
jours
mais quand vous vivez dedans quand vous
avez passé deux confinement là deux ans
et demi là croyez moi c'est pas il
paraît que c'est extrêmement froid pour
vous l'hiver pour Marie c'est froid
l'hiver c'est très chaud l'été là
c'était c'était l'horreur et pour
trouver l'électricité c'est très tous
les jours ça coûte du fric parce que
tous les jours vous pouvez pas vous
garer où vous voulez avec un truc comme
ça vous êtes obligé d'aller dans des
endroits précis donc c'est entre 15 et
20 euros tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours quand vous chauffez
l'hiver et une bouteille de butane qui
coûte 40 euros elle vous dure une
semaine vous voyez ça ça engendre tout
ça ça engendre des frais qui qui
n'aurait pas lieu d'être alors il y a
pas mal de Nancy qui dit est-ce que vous
avez des proches
pas proposé peut-être de vérifier qui
chez qui on va de temps en temps prendre
une douche chaude faire une machine mais
qui a des problèmes il y a ces problèmes
à lui et qu'il y a des problèmes de
couple
à me rendre fou votre histoire
de place pour nous héberger donc mais
cette dame là ce qu'elle a un cœur un
moment est-ce qu'elle voit la vie et
l'état de pierre et de Maryse
aujourd'hui si moi j'ai voilà j'en
appelle je me dis est-ce qu'un moment il
a été opéré
il a été opéré deux fois du cœur il a eu
un cancer de la vessie tu sais fou
elle ne veut pas partir et on sait pas
pourquoi alors ce matin ce matin on a
fait pas mal d'interviews ces jours-ci
ce matin des des des journalistes de TF1
sont allés la voir elle leur a dit
écoutez moi je veux pas partir c'est la
faute à l'agent c'est l'agence qui a mal
fait les choses vous comprenez mais
alors apprendre à des propos qui sont
qui sont à l'incohérents et c'est tout
elle travaille comment comment elle elle
ne paye plus hein
jusqu'à fait dans la vie pendant qu'elle
est pas là vous vous rentrez dans la
maison
la loi dit quoi Gilles violations de
domicile
parce que parce que comme elle avait un
bail au départ elle est considérée comme
locataire et pas juridiquement soit
heure et elle s'abrite autour de ça
c'est-à-dire qu'elle reporte de six mois
en 6 mois elle vous dit oui peut-être un
jour mais en fait elle ne fait rien
parce que elle sait très bien que en
diluant comme ça c'est juste le préfet
c'est pour ça que les missions est
importante c'est comme ça
qui peut débloquer alors le préfet on va
en parler dans un instant juste
aujourd'hui vous payez vous-même les
factures ce que vous avez vu on a payé
sono cette dame puisque elle ne veut pas
la payer donc vous payer le camping-car
vous payez tous les à côté de l'Opéra
notre taxe d'habitants donc toute façon
si on est on est dans un état où on a
plus envie de rien le brûle notre vie un
associé
au resto même si on avait les moyens on
a plus envie de rien on a on a que ça
Marie si vous avez perdu vos amis vous
avez perdu quand vos amis vos
amis vous allez inviter quelqu'un dans
un truc pareil vous allez faire venir
des amis de rien voilà vous allez vous
allez faire une Noël un truc comme ça
vous pouvez pas c'est
bousiller c'est le mot marseillais je
suis désolé bien sûr des fois j'ai envie
de recevoir ma petite fille et tout
banquier qui est grande et tout je
voudrais
à droite à gauche
c'est incroyable sinon incroyable alors
aujourd'hui vous avez des difficultés
financières aussi forcément mais c'est
pas bien parce qu'il faut payer les
huissiers il faut payer l'avocat c'est
pas facile il faut payer il faut payer
je vous jure ça me rend fou vous avez
tenté de faire un intervenir la police
et vous a dit qu'il y avait rien à faire
non la police tant que le préfet ne
donne pas l'ordre la police ne peut rien
faire donc là le préfet doit donner
l'ordre avant octobre
sinon c'est jusqu'au 15 mars dans le
passé
j'en appelle vraiment au préfet et voilà
on l'a vu pierre a eu des gros problèmes
de santé Maryse elle est moi je suis
dépressive et je suis supposable je ne
peux plus je suis toujours en train de
pleurer là j'ai pris des médicaments
pour pas pleurer mais
je suis pas bien je suis pas bien
on a plus de vie on a envoyé je sais pas
combien de lettres
une lettre à Monsieur Dupont été Gérard
de la Darmanin le préfet de police la
préfète le préfet de région
le procureur de la République le maire
de Marseille les huissiers et les
avocats personne nous a répondu alors
oui
je le fais passer à qui et le monsieur
Dupont-Moretti qui a envoyé à lui
là
et puis qui sont secrétariat nous a
envoyé un petit mot disant qu'ils
allaient voir
alors justement alors aujourd'hui donc
vous avez contacté énormément de gens
il faut donc ce soir avant le 30 octobre
31 octobre prochain jour de la trêve
hivernale vous avez donc écrit la
préfecture des Bouches-du-Rhône ils
assurent que le dossier sera examiné
dans les meilleurs délais et avec la
plus grande attention
est-ce que Gilles aujourd'hui on y croit
au 31 honnêtement les termes prêtes à
toutes les interprétations ça veut pas
dire grand chose dans les plus brefs
délais vous avez déjà eu ça c'est ça
l'inquiétude votre inquiétude extrême
c'est que seul le préfet peut trancher
et on me sent pas pour le moment une
volonté du préfet de prendre la décision
il faut le dire vraiment c'est pour ça
que Cyril l'émission peut faire
accélérer les choses parce que le pour
le moment le préfet n'a rien fait et on
n'a pas l'impression qu'il va signer
dans la semaine alors justement est-ce
que l'expulsion donc pour vous ne va pas
être possible compliqué puisque les
squatteurs sur la décision de justice
votre action et reçoivent puisque
l'exploitons ont été condamnés à quitter
les lieux j'ai le voilà j'ai ici la
décision de justice oui mais pour
qu'elle soit exécutée cette décision
comme elle est locataire au début
qu'elle
[Musique]
que vous vous passiez pas l'hiver vous
avez essayé l'hiver vous avez essayé de
lui dire qu'on allait la loger quelque
part où est-ce que vous avez pas essayé
de trouver quelqu'un qui va qui va le
bien immobilier
elle peut aller dans un mobil-home 700 €
un mobil-home sur
Vitrolles Vitrolles il est pas question
il est pas question elle a dit au juge
elle a dit je veux vivre décemment j'ai
mis 20 ans pour le payer donc
il faut que le ferraille point final
après donc je sais je sais que au niveau
de la procédure vous allez me dire je
sais que quand il y a des gens sont
expulsés comme ça bien souvent ils
laissent pas la rue et il est il y a des
organismes sociaux il y a des il y a ce
qu'il faut autour bah peut-être qu'elle
attend ça madame alors si vous nous
rejoignez à 21h09 on est en direct nous
sommes avec Pierre et Maryse cette
affaire elle est folle ils sont obligés
de dormir dans un camping-car alors
qu'ils ont une maison à eux qu'ils ont
payé et leur locataires refuse de partir
elle ne paye plus le loyer elle ne paye
plus l'eau aujourd'hui vous êtes
étranglés financièrement vous vous
dormez dans un camping-car vous êtes
retraités il y a l'hiver qui arrive
malade vous êtes malade vous avez eu des
des des des pathologies très très
compliquées et graves aujourd'hui la
lettre sachez-le si vous nous rejoignez
elle est et l'ordonnance et sur le
bureau du préfet si le préfet prend la
décision avant le 31 octobre on va
pouvoir sortir cette dame et vous allez
pouvoir reprendre votre maison si c'est
après le 31 il y a la trêve hivernale
vous devez attendre jusqu'au 15 mars ce
qui fait que vous allez repasser un
hiver donc au moins parce qu'après au
moins encore dans votre camping-car
aujourd'hui
sachez-le si vous arrivez seulement sur
l'émission Maryse et Pierre ils ne
vivent plus
je crois que vous avez aussi un peu
honte de la situation
dans notre situation parce que des fois
quand on va des désert ou quoi que les
gens ils parlent vraiment on parle
presque plus à plus personne
venez à la maison venez à la maison vous
garer le truc
mais nous on retrait parce qu'on est
rentré de tout on est entrées
on a travaillé tous les deux il est
resté 40 ans dans la même boîte toute sa
vie moi c'est pareil
c'est pas c'est pas une villa que j'ai
un petit appartement voilà une petite
maison de village
ferme toutes les fenêtres ça c'est
l'état qu'on a tout reflé dans lequel on
a loué
comme ça
il y a une vue sur la mer c'est à
l'Estaque sur la mer
à la limite c'est pas c'est pas
tellement ça le problème cette personne
un jour a mis sur facebook elle a dit
recherche appartement avec sur l'Estaque
avec vue sur mer cette dame là ne veut
pas aller habiter n'importe où
pour noter spectateurs
si on fait scandale dans le juge ça va
nous porter tort donc il nous
m'échappement entrer donc on n'a jamais
eu on a vu une fois on n'a jamais
discuter cette dame moi ce que je
comprends pas et c'est ce que
comprennent pas les téléspectateurs qui
réagissent énormément là à 21h12 on est
en direct si vous avez tout bien fait
vous avez fait des choses dans les
règles vous avez été vous avez été d'une
patience incroyable je le dis si
si leur cas n'est pas réglé il va se
passer il va se passer des drames parce
que la prochaine fois moi je vais aller
mettre devant la maison avec la voiture
je bouge plus je bouge plus non mais
au-delà parce que les gens à qui ça va
arriver ils vont dire moi j'ai vu pierre
et Maryse ils ont tout fait bien et ben
ils se retrouvent dans un camping-car il
se trouve étranglé leur vie est gâchée
et ben ils vont dire on va pas attendre
et on va se faire on va on va on va se
faire et ça va créer des drames et c'est
sûr et certain je vous le dis non mais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut agir vite et
j'en appelle vraiment au préfet vraiment
qui a sûrement un cœur qui a sûrement
suivi votre affaire et et qui peut pas
vous laisser comme ça vous pouvez pas
passer un hiver de plus dans le
camping-car je vous dis quand je vois
les yeux de Pierre les yeux de Marie
je sais pas comment on peut laisser ces
gens là comme ça voilà je je pourrai
voilà de de notre famille à tous quand
on vous voit ce soir tous les Français
qui nous regardent se disent comment on
peut laisser deux personnes dans une
telle détresse
et j'espère que ça va bouger mais c'est
vrai que Maryse je sais que j'ai envie
vraiment que vous reprenez le moral
c'est dur
c'est dur parce que
j'ai plus d'espoir parce que je vois que
c'est c'est tout le temps pareil il a
aucun
vous l'aurez pas vous voyez on est là
tout le temps à atteindre et moi
heureusement que je dois je dors pas la
nuit vous voyez je dors pas la nuit et
la première chose que je fais le matin
je
j'allume la télévision ça je suis tombé
l'autre matin juste comme ça je j'ai
allumé la télé et je regarde BFM
Marseille
et je vois un petit carré comme ça et je
vois qu'il y avait la préfète de police
qui allait parler
à BFM j'ai appelé ma maman Marie j'ai
dit couteau regarde si on envoyait un
petit mot peut-être que ça va nous aider
ça et et c'est comme ça que c'est parti
et qu'on a essayé et bon et puis tout ça
a été hier toute la journée aujourd'hui
on a eu le droit de l'histoire c'est que
ça va être très long pour nous pour se
remettre de tout ça si on s'en remet un
jour ça va pas être évident ça va pas
être évident parce qu'il faut garder
espoir la pierre et Marie j'espère que
ça va bouger on va tout faire et
j'espère que cette émission va faire
bouger les choses pour qu'avant le 31
octobre vous puissiez retrouver votre
maison parce que vous voir comme ça je
vous dis on peut pas aller ce soir tous
ceux qui nous regardent tous ceux qui
ont vu Pierre et Marie ce soir on peut
pas voilà se dire on va aller se coucher
tranquille sans penser à vous ce soir on
va tous penser à vous et vraiment je
vous dis on va tout faire pour que ça ça
se règle on va prendre des nouvelles
très régulièrement et vraiment votre
noir et je le dis moi l'argument numéro
un si Pierre et Maryse c'est Pierre et
Marie n'arrive pas à s'en sortir et à
retrouver leur maison je vous le dis
tous les gens qui ont entendu cette
histoire qui ont lu cette histoire dans
les journaux vont dire Pierre et Marie
ils ont fait les choses dans les règles
ils se sont retrouvés comme ils se sont
retrouvés aujourd'hui et bien ça va
donner des drames parce que les gens
vont dire nous on va se faire justice
nous-mêmes très vite
elle est au bout du rouleau